- We have one more uplifting
story I wanna share.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience clap)
Martin Luther King said,
"Life's most persistent
and urgent question is, what
are you doing for others?"
This next lesson proves even
the smallest act of kindness
can be life-changing.
Five years ago, Sharon was
homeless and saw a stranger
who looked as if she could
use some cheering up.
So Sharon picked some flowers
and handed them to the woman
along with a butterfly sticker.
The next day that stranger told Sharon
that just before they met,
she'd been planning to commit suicide.
Woof, it's like I already
knew I was gonna say it,
but that's hard to say.
The flowers and sticker
changed everything.
From that moment on Sharon vowed
she'd do random kind gestures
as often as she could,
you know, as often as possible.
And today, not only is
she back on her feet,
she's the founder of Never
Give Up Never Quit, a charity
dedicated to her mission.
(audience clap)
We have Sharon on the line
right now watching on WKYC3
Cleveland at 11:00 am.
(audience cheer and clap)
Hello, hi.
- Hey, Kelly Clarkson and everyone.
- Oh, you look so cute,
like I wanna hug you.
So wait, tell us more about
Never Give Up Never Quit.
- In 2018, we officially became
a charitable organization
of random acts of kindness.
This came after my season
of homelessness, Kelly.
I drive a motivational
vehicle all over my city.
I travel outside of my
city to other cities
with a team of volunteers.
We pack that truck out, Kelly.
We open it up and we give
random acts of kindness.
Some of the things
- [Kelly] Well done.
that we give, Kelly, are
motivational T-shirts,
we give food, restaurant gift
cards, hats, gloves, coats,
and we also give our Willy Wonka soaps.
We're the Willy Wonkas of soap, Kelly.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- And when we go to the shelters, Kelly,
a lot of them have
problems with their skin,
so I specialize in making medicine soaps.
We use them to fundraise.
- Oh, that's such an amazing
thing that you're doing.
So, a lot of your volunteers
pass out the items
while wearing costumes.
So why do they do that?
- So, we began this because
I go to high schools
and do empowerment presentations, Kelly.
So what we say is one
of my favorite sayings,
don't let nothing or
no one clip your wings.
The honeybee and the butterfly
- [Kelly] Oh, I love that.
cannot fly without wings
and if we don't have good thoughts,
if we don't choose to have good thoughts,
we cannot have good mental health, Kelly.
So we encourage the people with our wings
to be careful not to
let anything clip you.
- Oh, I love that.
It's so funny, that's
literally a line in a song
that's like, I'm making for my next album.
It's literally about
you try to clip my wings
and it's such a great thing
because it literally is so true.
'Cause I feel like people
will try and get at you
and it's like, not today, Satan.
I'm keeping both my wings in tact.
Well, thank you so much, Sharon.
I love what you're doing,
we love what you're doing.
I'm liking your posts right now, right?
- [Sharon] Thank you.
- Well, that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show,
Want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you ma'am.
So, they will be writing you
a check for a thousand dollars
to help out.
(audience cheer and clap)